plus abel je sais je sais qui c'est et
vercingétorix est-ce que vous aviez eu
un amour secret un show vous avez jamais
jamais dit genre une parenté a oui bah
déjà dit mcdowell
bah si tu sais puisque c'est l'été passe
comme ça c'est plus que pas secret
basescu banon mais j'ai eu un jeu les
vues de près quand même pas vraiment
quand vous avez pécho de dix matches où
on a je voulais raconter déjà qu'on
n'arrive pas à y croire
tu vas live et naïma chaussures ronald
mcdonald avec l'ajout balles ont été
clonés sa sévère mais ça a duré très peu
de temps en fait franchement parce que
non mais c'est review c'est bizarre hein
dès qu'une fille couche avec vous de
bukit la clé de la porte
ça doit être un peu de temps j'étais
très vexé en fait marié avec elle parce
que tout ce que vous avez déjà vu un
amour secret quand la femme d'à côté
stéphanie arbonne qui jouer avec l'âge
de 15-16 ans c'est vrai qu'elle est
vallespir et le laisse couler le show
band
non mais enfin la caf pour la pêche au
boitier je peux dire tu vas payer mais
non mais non mais non pécho d'ailleurs
alors il est vrai mais j'étais dire non
mais je vous ai pas pu m
isabelle je sais je sais qu'ici
bersinger théorie parce que je n'ai pas
eu ou élevé qu ils sont tous ça vous
ennuie 3,4 et vous voulez c'est non mais
dites nous à haïti avec qui vous avez
pécho que vous avez siobhan vous savez
où le prof de ski le machin vous ça vous
les connaissez n'y a pas de secret il
dit avec une star hollywoodienne
tu as online star tim cook book
imaginez-vous des profils c'était la nsa
jones à il ya dix ans lorsqu'elle venait
à changer à la première musicale 3 y
avait eu des échanges un peu longue ou
re et c'est quoi des échanges vigoureux
changer fait comme ça tu bloques c'est
le regard au moins 3 4 secondes
j'estime que si quelque chose à mon avis
tu vois passer jeudi un mandat mais vous
a pris pour la semaine du cheval à bout
à oui laurence que j'ai rencontré en
seconde c'est 8 à savigny sur orge et
grâce à vos équipes
je suis amoureux d'elle depuis tout
petit grâce à ses sympathies et le nom
alors moi je vais vous dire j'ai couché
avec tous les gens que j'aimais à bon
entendeur
moi j'ai juste après vous dire salut à
bonne entendeur
les hommes même joue se servant des
seniors et grichka non non moi je ne
m'attends pas pour ceux qui veulent
venir chercher la personne n'a rien eu
mais roa sur qui va s'habituer au bas de
votre écran souvenirs et chasser avant
20 heures 10
[Musique]